Welcome to the Developer Bus 2013
the challenge that will combine
Development, work groups and effort
as well as the potential of Google technology
We invite Latin American developers and
we challenge them to create useful app for local industry
In just 3 days, by creating apps and
innovative solutions
Who can participate? If you are a
developer, designer or you're good at business
you can register and participate, in the cities
in which the Bus will stop this seasson
Buenos Aires, Mexico City, Bogota or
Sao Paulo
The winners will get up on the bus with us
for a final event in Silicon Valley
where all the regional talent
will be shown
The Developer Bus as well is a social
reality, transmitted live on YouTube and Google+
the whole world would be able to
live this experience